a foto pessoal daqui fala dar que seja
muito bem vindo a mais um vídeo eu gosto
sabes aqui como hipnotizado um cão é
verdade eu encontrei um vídeo na
internet onde mostra claramente que é um
cão que está completamente climatizado
por uma luz eu achei esse vídeo bem
curioso eu vou assistir aqui com vocês
mesmo vocês vão ver o que é que se trata
realmente o cão está hipnotizar é
incrível ainda não vem com a portal
informática do peão dele também por isso
eu não sei se funciona mesmo pra ver o
vídeo ok como podem ver temos aqui uma
lanterna luz
se a pessoa está a tomar banho devagar e
temos aqui o cão olhar para alguns
natureza ele está completamente pelo
whatsapp logo ele fica quieto olhar para
ele como é que isto é possível
e aí
e não é que tu tá fixamente olhar para
fazer mais não
e como é que eu preciso e vê-se
claramente tal e alguém filmar médica
pessoa está ali ao lado e norma muitas
vezes olham que fazer o que é que se
passa o meu então tá só na água e o que
é que nós vamos fazer vamos testar hoje
aqui neste vídeo se dá realmente para
hipnotizar um cão eu tenho aqui muitos
materiais de que não temos muito eu
encontrei também fui pesquisar na net o
que é que dá para finalizar as pessoas e
os cães os cães eram conseguir encontrar
muita de este tipo de coisas inclusive
eu tenho aqui a lanterna para tentar
explicar o vídeo eu vou tentar comprar
uns parede e vamos ver o que é que vai
dar o suquinho ainda por cima ele
sentido umas atitudes estranhas aqui em
casa uso que consegue que me comunicar
comigo de uma forma que eu nunca vi
outro cão a fazer houve um dia destes
que eu tava aqui para brincar com ele
tava em cima do meu comando comando da
tv e eu estava a ver o netflix
entretanto tipo sem atenção então e ele
no comando escreve tipo lá na busca
começou assim um site sabem que escreve
a palavra para ele usou algum atalho
assim meu foi completamente cana
obviamente que eu não ia ter
inteligência para escrever isso hoje não
entende desse treino vocês ficam a
pensar não é eu estou a brincar com o
uso que está entediado ela não está a
gostar
e para mesmo em frente a mim na tv é
para normal não percebemos é muito
estranho é mas hoje vamos tentar
descobrir suzuki pelo menos é
hipnotizavel eu não sei se essa palavra
existe mas ok eu tinha aqui a lanterna
para a funcionar ok tenho aqui um apito
de cão
o apartamento estilo som ultrassônico
então só esquentar conseguem ouvir tem
essa coisa aqui que roda olha aí temos
aqui aquele tipo pêndulo faz a pessoa
concentrar porque a base o hipnotismo
acho que é fazer a pessoa relaxar ok e a
pessoa vai seguir as sugestões que o
hipnotizador está a dar ok essa é a base
do hipnotismo é meu ver basicamente o
que eu tenho que fazer é relaxar os
últimos vai ser bem difícil porque ele é
um cão muito agitado estou curioso para
ver como é que ele vai reagir com esta
lanterna duas que se ele vai reagir como
aquele cão que está no vídeo ou de forma
diferente talvez mais assustá-la mas
assustador nem precisei do biscoito
e aí
nós estamos aqui então é inscrito muito
bem para vocês verem como o que está
obediente certa
me dá um beijinho
e da pata direita rebola muito bem como
fazer um vídeo para ter o comida deles
assenta dá um beijo dá a pata direita e
ainda rebola portanto ele já tem mais ou
menos usando somos daquilo que está a
fazer não está mais ou menos treinado né
não vai dar flores florais
[Música]
e não
e já
e ai ai ai
e bora lá então pessoal vou tentar
hipnotizado zouk com vamos tentar
primeiro o pêndulo é forma clássica
disso não tiver pessoas
e sabe o que isto é normal que não sabes
português um cão os cães não conhecem
essas coisas senta sempre
e esse vídeo vai ser difícil primeira
tentativa de finalizar os outros e
[Música]
e não não é suposto que está sentada e
se concentrar em
e aí
e não está comprar o que é que está a
passar aqui eu posso te hipnotizar olha
para aqui isso que olha que é que na
concentração concentração vai dar isso é
impossível concentra-te 1
oi você vai vir
é tu que não é tipo de esperar atenção
como se com cê não vai dar em nada como
se com certeza
eu consegui mais relaxados o que tu
estás relaxar tivessem climatizado e
um ok eu sou se deitou isso não está
resultado vamos tentar com o apetite cão
pode ser que eu tenho uma reação eu quis
o que é que se passa o que é que tá não
tive o teu errado certa
um ok o plano tá aí de tudo por água
abaixo o apito também não funciona vale
a pena ficar mais biscoitos que eu tenho
para ele a máquina inteligente o que eu
pensei e não se deixa hipnotizar assim
provavelmente isso aqui para largar o
carro acho que estou coisa vai resultar
porque acho que eu nunca vi o está
frente isso aqui é um daqueles círculos
que quando roda tipo faz aquele efeito o
psicadélico sabem que fica dela e nem se
sente que se diz mas vocês perceberam
faces olharem bem no centro da assim que
ela que ela ilusão de ótica né mas vamos
ver a reação dela com isto
a calma
[Música]
e não no caso aqui ó
a concentração cal concentra não
e aqui onde aqui ó
e pela luta não eu só riacho dizer para
ir à rua a capetinha capetinha da pata
da deita deita rebola muito bem muito
bem muita coisa pessoal muitas das vezes
eu cuido dos o que aqui em casa tipo
corte as unhas porte o pelo que ele tem
assim a mais nas patas e já está entrar
naquela fazenda tenho que voltar a fazer
isso então vocês acharam importante
mostrar aqui para o canal ou não comenta
embaixo pessoal porque assim eu
aproveito e faço um vídeo vai lá então
só continuar aqui a tentar aqui no
whatsapp suzuki ele só parece meio
chateado com espinhos eu vou tentar
despachar eu vou tentar fazer aqui
rápido eu não sei olha só está a
esconder debaixo da mesa olha aí outra
coisa pessoal no vídeo anterior eu fiz
aqui a customização de uma playstation 4
eu passei lá alguém também estar na
descrição ficou incrível como podem ver
então é fácil ainda se o vosso apoio
para lá então pessoal vamos ver se o que
fica entre nós
a lanterna e em 3 2 1
o meu liso que não acredito concentração
muita calma concentração e olha aquilo e
e aí
fala galera é
e o que és o que é o que não quis o que
é isto
e aí
e eu não tenho comida aqui que é isto
o que é que só alguma coisa é facto ele
quando olha para aquela luz fica um
pouco estranho e eu não sei porque ele
tá ali meio parado atua em frente à luz
simplesmente não estava olhar para a luz
como o outro cão do vídeo mas está ali
para
e olha lá eu muitos à frente da luz eu
não sei o que é que tá acontecer é
bizarro na mesma eu não sei se ele está
aqui pelo whatsapp mas está ali que atua
há muito tempo
e aí
e o que é que se passa estamos o que é
what só o quê que vocês acham será que
tem que matizar é que lhe falta ali
quieto e vocês viram a pouco a pouco ele
tava muito muito agitado e agora só tá
ali em frente à luz não sei o que é que
se passou eu no início até tava um pouco
agitado mas eu esperei um pouquinho
espera ele se habituar a luz e ele agora
é só está ok então já pelos ele não sabe
o que é aquilo e tal ou que fez o quê é
o quê
[Música]
e aí
eu não quis o que vai para outra vez
[Música]
para chegar agora
e ele tá desconfiado alguma coisa já não
sabe ao certo o que aqui mas ele fica
ali como se tivesse a produzir aquela
luz só faça uma coisa tentei fazer isso
em casa se tiver em algum cão algum gato
eu ponto em uma luz para a parede e
filme a reação dele façam tipo de
história e assim e partilhem com ele
rouba tiver engraçado eu vou partilhar
também o repouso obviamente não podem
alunos diretamente para a cara das
vossos cães e dos vossos gatos ok mas
tente fazer esta ponte solos para a
parede e vejo o que é com como faz pode
ser que eles não têm a reação do vídeo
pode ser que outros tem outros tipos de
reações o seu que só ficar lá embaixo da
luz a produzir da luz não sei mais o que
eu não sei o que é que ele pensa que
aquilo é mas mas é isso pessoal espero
que vocês tenham gostado aqui deste
vídeo não resultou tão bem como eu
queria é como um vídeo principal o que
nós vimos mas foi interessante a reação
dos o quê porque ele ficou aqui ó ainda
está aqui ainda continua sentado como se
algo estivesse aqui não faço ideia é que
passou mas já sabem pessoal se quiser
engravidar também o histórico o vosso
cachorrinho olhar para a luz vejam a
reação dele particular no instagram
a pesquisa alí ver vídeos da tarde
todinha olha aí tá cansado o que estou
ali já sabem se quiserem ver mais vídeos
também a tratar suzuki aqui do pelo e
das unhas dele comentem também vai sair
de boa vida de desenvolvida muito bem
pessoal espero que vocês tenham gostado
fiquem bem e até a próxima
e aí